so here's an interesting thought
experiment do we have the capacity to
change the past now at first this sounds
like a contradiction a total paradoxical
idea I mean how could you change
something that already happened but
think about it why does the past matter
at all what do we get to keep from
something that already happened well we
get to keep the memory right supposedly
either the bliss or the trauma it's
really the memory that we're talking
about here the story that runs on a loop
in the back of our minds of what has
happened and somehow the fact that what
has happened has shaped us and will
shape our future we feel in a way
haunted or condemned to be a certain way
because of what has happened to us
epigenetics tells us that we are the sum
of our experiences that we that our
cells are a technology that turns
experience into biology that everything
that happens to us lays itself like tire
tracks tattooing itself across our body
mind and literally making us the product
of what has come before and yet and yet
here's something amazing our cognitive
framing our interpretation our use of
rhetoric and language to frame our past
experiences can actually allow us to
change our very past experience so so
the story we tell the story we choose to
tell about what has happened can change
what has happened listen to that again
because they've actually done studies
that tell us that the cognitive framing
that we give to experiences can change
our physiological response to those very
experiences so an experience of trauma
seen through a certain lens can
physiologically create stress response
right cortisol stress hormones anxiety
all these things but people who do
for example psychedelic hypnotherapy and
revisit the trauma through this altered
state of consciousness or all of a
sudden able to change that story change
their chemical response to that past
experience recontextualize it and see it
through a different lens and
fundamentally change the past you know
it's a great line by Tim duty that says
that experiences that are transformative
in nature that allow us to change the
cognitive framing of who we are and
where we're going in this life and where
we've been
our experiences that recontextualize the
self as a marvelous conduit in a
timeless hole from which molecules and
meanings flow from neurons to nebula and
back again and in recontextualizing who
we are and what we're doing and
everything that happens to us even when
it hurts and even when we fall off the
bicycle in Amsterdam and like literally
get caught up the fact of the matter is
that story has now rendered me a
stronger being it is something that has
happened and that I have overcome
I have not choked on my intro versions I
have in fact reworked the experience and
out put it in a work of art I am more
than what I was because of what has
happened to me and this decision right
this decision to lend that cognitive
framing to lend that interpretation to a
traumatic experience of the past has
allowed me to change the past and
therefore to sort of change my future
and decide my fate I design therefore I
become again beautiful idea my friends
we are empowered we are in raptured we
are beings that move through time and
space and space and time and mind and
future and past and present these are
basically just elements of a continuous
field of time they don't exist they are
illusions and you can choose the story
you tell my friends you can choose the
story you tell
you